bom dia branquinha vocês conhecem todos
hoje vocês quando estudava você tinha um
caderno e uma caneta
vocês tinham uma lousa com o professor
dá aula ou mesmo professor
se você respondeu sim há pelo menos duas
dessas perguntas você é um privilegiado
é tanto perguntas parecem meio boba
assim poxa afinal que não tem um caderno
uma caneta
infelizmente essa não é a realidade que
a gente encontra aqui no brasil e agora
em um tablet quentinha
a gente teve tudo começou lá em 2012 com
um projeto chamado dante mobile que
visava colocar um tablet na mão de cada
aluno do ensino médio aqui nesse colégio
mas a gente não queria simplesmente
fazer um projeto para os alunos porque
afinal de contas eles iam usar esses
dispositivos
é melhor fazer um projeto com os alunos
para que eles pudessem opinar assim
surgiu o comitê gestor se sente um grupo
de alunos que se reúne toda quinta feira
aqui no colégio para discutir para
discutir a gestão móvel desses aparelhos
além da de como a didática na sala
de aula feita os aplicativos que vão ser
usados usadas e nesse projeto teve o
comitê gestor existentes que era um
comitê em que justamente a gente
discutir o que a gente podia fazer e
além disso a gente podia fazer projetos
essa foi a primeira vez que falaram pra
gente aqui vocês podem concretizar
realizar o que vocês desejam mas a gente
só tinha 17 ea gente pensou bom com 17
anos
o que eu posso fazer como eu posso
ajudar a sociedade e será que vai mesmo
ser bom e se concretizar o que pensa
esse grupo se tocou com um problema em
2014 com o terceiro nestas a gente não
sabia o que fazer com os aparelhos
móveis que pertenciam a eles e que eles
reclamavam muito eu falo que a internet
não funcionava direito que os
aplicativos não abriam que nada naquele
aparelho funcionava mas será que não
funcionava mesmo porque o que eles
falavam é realmente que a internet
demorar um minuto para
mas será que para outras pessoas e se um
minuto é importante
será que realmente é uma demora assim
surgiu o projeto ajudante um projeto que
visava pegar esses aparelhos que eram
usados pelos acionistas e doados a
instituições carentes
só que a gente não queria simplesmente
do ato doha porque ia fazer isso
qualquer um faz
então a gente pensou em modos que a
gente podia é fazer diferente
a gente começou com as instituições que
a gente pensou bom se a gente
simplesmente doar para uma instituição
realmente qualquer um faz
mas será que eles têm todo o preparo
será que eles têm mas fai para usar esse
tablet e além de tudo isso a gente tinha
um problema que os alunos reclamam dos
aparelhos
então a gente estava ver como é que os
aparelhos estavam de verdade então a
gente recolher todos os aparelhos e
todos eles passarão por uma análise
técnica
depois dessa análise a gente viu os
aparelhos estavam em boas condições para
continuar em uso
recolhemos deles e fizemos a doação a
gente começou a pesquisar nas
instituições e uma delas que a gente
trabalhou foi o accord que na verdade o
dante já trabalha a gente é já faz uma
função social ea renda que trabalhar com
quem a gente já tem experiência o
resultado vai realmente se a aparelho
que a outra que a gente escolheu é uma
ong chamada quintal da criança é uma ong
aqui na baixada do glicério em são paulo
que acolhe filhos de catadores de lixo
enquanto os pais trabalham onde as
crianças não têm onde ficar como estão
de ensino e mesmo assim doando
será que os professores não têm preparo
será que os alunos não saber como
utilizar o aparelho porque se eles não
têm nenhum caderno nem o lápis será que
eles vão saber utilizar esse aparelho
para ensino justamente como a gente
queria porque a mesma coisa que a gente
pegar e dá um iphone para a nossa avó
nossa volta
com mais ou menos uns 80 anos eu não
tinha computador ela mal sabia que um
tablet vai pegar com a nossa um iphone
eu sei mexer nisso
então a gente resolveu fazer a formação
dos profissionais das instituições
a gente chamou está a vir aqui o colégio
e é feita essa formação com
profissionais de tecnologia educacional
daqui do colégio além de professores de
diversas matérias que já trabalham muito
bem com esses dispositivos em sala de
aula
outra coisa que a gente pensou essa
formação contado acho que a gente teve
que a gente simplesmente lavar a gente
vai formar com estudante
na verdade é muito mais do que isso foi
muito mais na verdade né porque nas
aulas de história por exemplo a gente
usava ou tablet pra perceber o que
estava acontecendo ao redor do mundo a
gente correlacionava com matérias
isso é muito importante porque a pessoa
ela se forma realmente como uma pessoa
era isso que a gente queria passar por
esses alunos não simplesmente uma
formação em que a gente dá vontade ele
vai pegar o livro de biologia pegava um
aplicativo e via como funciona a
circulação e tal
tudo isso é muito legal mas a gente
queria além disso ainda mais um aluno
que não tenha uma caneta para escrever
ele não vai ter promoção de um
laboratório de química
só que com dispositivo móvel e consegue
ele consegue baixar um aplicativo que
vai mostrar como é feita todas as
reações químicas que seriam feitos no
laboratório ele consegue criar uma
autonomia em si e não precisa mais só do
professor para aprender
ele aprende sozinho então a gente pensou
que realmente o tablet podia superar
esses problemas o problema de muitas
vezes não têm o caderno tem a caneta em
seu laboratório de química um teu livro
fica complicado estudar essa foto é do
dia que a gente fez a doação ao quintal
da criança como vocês podem ver são
majoritariamente crianças de zero a sete
anos
nesse dia a gente contou além de todo o
comitê gestor do centcom profissionais
aqui do colégio e outro em alguns
profissionais da própria instituição
nessa outra foto é o dia da doação ao a
corte
a gente conta com os jovens adultos que
fazem parte do projeto aqui dentro do
colégio além de alguns profissionais do
colégio e da instituição
nessa última a gente vê um aparelho que
não tinha mais utilidade né
ele era lento é o aplicativo não abrir
era complicado assim
no colégio como os alunos deveriam
realmente ele caiu em desuso como a
gente pode ver sendo que essas crianças
estão usando porque para elas é aquele
um minuto que a internet demora não faz
diferença porque ela não teve essa
oportunidade antes eu queria agradecer
muito a todos vocês estão aqui hoje nos
deixando compartilhar um pouco mais a
nossa experiência eu vou passar um vídeo
agora que eu acho que o vídeo mostra é
muito melhor do que qualquer privilégio
que a gente possa ter
ae
esse vídeo ele foi feito no dia da
entrega o quintal da criança eles
resolveram cantar algumas músicas pra
gente nos agradecendo pelo projeto e
assim a gente agradece vocês mas a gente
não queria estar aqui infelizmente pra
compartilhar o que foi o projeto e falar
o porquê a gente queria além
a gente queria mais que isso é deixar um
recado mesmo a gente queria que vocês
pensassem e um rastro de seus
privilégios e repensar em todas as suas
escolhas
obrigada